five four
three
[Music]
this is the ramsay
show you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
fine print and the entree leadership
podcast is my co-host today as we talk
about your relationships your boundaries
your mental health your
job your career your money your life
it's all right here it's called the
ramsay show we're going gonna talk about
you right in front of you the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five the call is free and
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it kyle is with us to
start off this hour in davenport iowa hi
kyle welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve man what's up
yeah i had a question we recently i'm a
union member and i recently resigned a
contract
and they're giving us a
one-time choice
of
we currently are offered a 401k and a
pension
and they're giving us a choice to freeze
the pension
for an increased match in the 401k
and i was just wondering your thoughts
on that
interesting
well i mean we would just try to figure
out the math on it wouldn't we yeah
so what is the increase in the 401k
match
um so
it's based on their return on assets per
year
which eight out of the last 12 years it
would be
dollar for dollar match up to six
percent
which i currently get 60 cents per
dollar
okay so it's a 40
increase
all right so two percent uh and what's
your household what do you make what do
you make with this job uh about about
90.
okay
so here's the deal 40
of 6
would be 2.4
follow me okay
that's the increase
that's the increase so 2.4 percent of 90
000 we're gonna round that up and call
it 2500 bucks
okay okay 2.5 percent of a hundred
thousand would be that so we're just
going to round it for easy math okay so
the benefit is 2500 bucks that's what
you're going to get
on a good year eight out of 10 years
eight out of 12 years or whatever so uh
then what are you giving up for 2 500
bucks a year
it's the pension increases 48 per year
of service
48 per year of what
of service
so every two years it goes up by a
hundred bucks
uh just about yeah
and that's the amount going in or the
amount going in per month or the amount
coming out
per year
going in
correct to the pension yeah
so they will either add 48 48
or you can or they will add 2500
correct
well that's kind of easy
yeah and then they would freeze it at my
current i have 11 years in already so
yeah you're just not you're not going to
get the increases that's what you're
giving up correct correct
well there's a cumulative effect of the
increases mathematically though because
it'd be 48 and then it'd be 48 and then
be 48 so every year it's it's it's 150
after three years
yes and how old are you
uh 34.
okay so if you work 20 years
um
yeah
it's still not going to be there still
not going to be to 2 500 bucks
correct per year and there's also
there's also one small other
piece to this is
they put into a
a retirement fund they put in
currently if i kept the pension and 401k
that i have they would put in three
percent of what i make a year
into a retirement account
once a year
and if i switched they would up that to
five percent
weekly man they want you out of this
pension bad
correct
but i also their pension their
their pension's in trouble
um
they're dude they're writing you check
for
what are we up to now uh 10x 20x to get
out
yeah
yeah get out i mean i'll take you know
read the tea leaves on that puppy
yeah here's the other advantage
the 401k over the pension is always an
advantage stop before we even start
doing the math and the reason is this
you died pension dies with you you die
with a million dollars your 401k it goes
to your heirs
yeah so you get to keep the asset when
it's in a 401k they keep the asset when
it's in a pension
correct and so 401 k all things being
equal always beats pension but this
thing is it starts to be a slam dunk you
got two and a half two point four
percent plus three percent
you know you're getting this thing
they're they're just they're they're
they're waving the flares aren't they
george oh yeah and with how young he is
that compound growth is going to do him
way better than the 48 dollars a year in
the pension so i'm taking that yeah when
you leave you can roll your 401k
whatever's in there the matches and
everything else
probably that retirement plan as well
out if you ever left the union you could
roll it out to uh
just to an a rollover ira into some
mutual funds so i i don't i mean unless
i'm missing something with the numbers
you're giving me it's
it's way more than a no-brainer
it's 2500 for 48
yeah
and i mean it's a lifetime of that
pension but beyond that like you're
saying it's gone when he's gone yeah
yeah and
yeah it's just he can become his own
pension at his age with how he's
investing
yeah he won't need it i'll pass yeah i'm
gonna take their deal i think i think
they're i think they're yelling at you
with the math
please get out quickly well i'm sure
you've seen the pensions are going away
year after year companies are moving
away from that into the 401k well
they're very difficult to manage and the
reason they're very difficult to manage
is the regulations on them are extreme
they're not allowed to do anything that
that we would normally do with our
investing because it's called too risky
they're not allowed to put the whole
thing in mutual funds that's very
concerning they have to they because
pensions in the old days ago broke so
the feds came in and over regulated them
to keep them from going broke to protect
the people so to speak but in the effort
to protect them they've ruined the
ability to operate a pension efficiently
so a pension typically is going to pay
six and a half to seven percent rate of
return out of it that's basically what
you're going to get out of it um and it
dies when you die but then you've got
the actuarial table built in because it
dies when you die and so if you've got
all the old guys are the major pension
holders and they're all out there this
thing could get upside down the young
guys are supporting the old guys kind of
like the young population yeah exactly
it becomes a pyramid scheme
because it's not earning enough to even
cover the payout and that's where they
get upside down because they're over
regulated so i'm not predicting the end
of the world but a lot of people are
moving away from pensions and now even
this union unions are one of the last
holdouts on pensions but even this union
is is dumping it and so
i think they're yelling at you to run
and i i believe i would
if they're scared i'm scared take the
hint
oh my goodness wow there we go
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you've ever been to one of our live
events you know they're all about the
life change that you and your family can
do and we're gonna show you how when you
come to an event you spend a whole day
digging into all areas of your life when
it comes to our smart conference
money personal growth leadership mental
health your career you will leave
informed and hyped up and ready to make
real change this is the smart
conference yep smart conference is back
it's been three years gosh it feels like
20. yeah we're so pumped to get this
event back on the road we're going to be
in dallas on october the 22nd george
campbell will be one of our speakers i
will be there it is going to be a great
event uh craig and amy groschell from
lifechurch.tv are going to be teaching
on marriage that will be a new segment
and they are really incredible you don't
want to miss this smart conference is
our biggest event of the year don't miss
it it's going to be a day-long
jam-packed event you get advice from
leading experts in every
field tickets start at just 39
it's a great price for a full day event
like this i promise you this is world
class
speakers communicators authors teachers
on all of these different areas of your
life you will leave smarter
go to ramseysolutions.com
events get your tickets now before
they're gone they're selling very
quickly
if you haven't noticed stuff like live
events people are blowing up on them
i think everybody's ready to get back
out there and do stuff with other human
beings again you know
like it's hard to get tickets to
anything and these are selling very
quickly ramsey solutions dot com
slash events and check out the smart
conference october the 22nd in
dallas
mary is in kalamazoo michigan hi mary
welcome to the ramsay show
hi hi dave
oh my gosh what a privilege it is to
speak with you you too um
oh thank you um
so i have something kind of laying heavy
on my heart and i was hoping to seek
your advice
um
so i'm 31 years old
my husband is
a couple years older than me and my
daughter is sick
i have a very close relationship with my
parents and they're in their 70s
they recently informed me that
my daughter and i will be receiving
um a little over a million dollars
in inheritance when they pass away
um which is is wonderful that's
very generous
um what i'm having a hard time with is
i'm adopted they're not my biological
parents
and they also informed me that my
brother
who is my father's biological son will
not even be receiving half of that
and
he and i don't have a good relationship
anyways i mean it's civil we're not
close by any means we're he's 20 years
older than i am
um
why the discrepancy and
i i think it's because they don't have a
very close relationship with him
he's from my father's first marriage
and they didn't raise them together
um
okay
so how can we help
so
my question is how can i get over this
themselves and
if and when they pass
how do i maintain a good relationship
with my brother when that happens
it sounds like you don't have a great
relationship right now with your brother
it's civil we enjoy seeing each other
but we we just have
such a huge age gap
and just completely different lives that
we don't really communicate with each
other that much yeah
okay
i think you need to free yourself of
this because it's not a decision you
made
so there's nothing to feel guilty about
there's relational equity that you have
with the family and that turns into
financial equity with the inheritance
the um
guilt would be if you did something you
didn't do anything
so and i think it's probably named wrong
uh instead let's name it something else
because i get that you have angst about
it i i get that you feel kind of like
ugh
why you know this is gonna not gonna go
well and i'm gonna get blamed
you know
that's kind of how it feels right
so i don't i don't know what we call
that but guilt would be if you did
something wrong you didn't do anything
so this is not on you
um you know unless you manipulated your
parents into a bigger inheritance but
that's not what you said so i'm i'm
going with you i'm going with your story
so uh first let's just say out loud your
parents are cowards
to dump this on you
they should call they should call him up
and tell him what he's getting and what
you're getting they did that with you
they they have informed him
that you're getting a million and he's
getting a half
he's getting about 300 000 okay have
they told him what you're getting
i believe so they thought that they
would all right so i had to ask them to
that's good that's what they should do
i'll retract my statement that they're
not cowards then if they did that
because they're dumping the problem of
the relational angst on you upon their
death if they don't handle it while
they're alive and so we tell people read
the will while you're alive and tell
everybody what they're getting and if
somebody's gonna be pissed let's go and
deal with it while i'm alive
and so if they've done that then i guess
brothers already got it figured out that
you didn't do anything
he already knows
okay
i would verify that they did that
with her with them i mean you told him
how much i'm getting and how much he's
getting if not you should mom and dad
because it's not fair to leave me
looking like the bad dog
the bad person at the end of this story
because i didn't do anything here
right okay and if they do that then
maybe brother just looks at it and goes
okay
i don't really talk to him that much
anyway and she hangs out over there all
the time i get it
like i have a relative who will leave
100
of their money
to
one child and will leave the other child
nothing who they have no relationship
with
and that's completely understandable i
have a relative that's doing that right
now and i agree with it by the way
and that's okay but but you shouldn't
you shouldn't again you're not entitled
to money just because of your dna you're
entitled to the money if somebody wants
to leave it to you it's their money they
get to do with what they want and so he
has no real gripe
to start with and so he's three hundred
thousand ahead of what he should be
probably but um but yeah thing is not
letting his resentment and anger towards
her be a reflection of her character
right this is has nothing to do with it
you didn't write this narrative
you just are in the story you didn't
write the story and so um i get that it
feels icky and i don't i really don't
disagree with you about that the only
way to remove that is shine when when
stuff is
awkward or weird the best way to clean
it up is shine light on it
call it out and all the roaches run to
the corner as soon as you turn on the
lights and so if you'll go ahead and
just call it out if they've already
called it out then he has the
opportunity to interact with them and if
he wants to be mad at you i guess he can
be he may call you and say i'm pissed at
you i don't know but at least he can get
all that out of the way now before the
money actually transfers
and
um and even then you just go
i didn't do it you know yeah you have a
conversation with them go hey i know
this is weird i had nothing to do with
this i still want to have this
relationship with you i love you yeah
you know and you move on from there and
if he can't handle that that's on him if
that relationship can't move on exactly
this is not she's just a good person and
with a big heart and she feels that
sweet well you feel it it is an
awkwardness crud
thing but the way to get rid of the
awkward is for mom and dad to tell him
the same thing they told her and the why
behind it
if the why is if they can do it without
being nasty
you know
and just go
this is just our decision and
you know you don't even have to you
don't have to hurt his feelings too
you know just tell him is what he's
getting is what she's getting and leave
it at that i
yeah
but this is why you do a will and this
is why you read the will out loud before
you die to all parties concerned
so that everyone knows what's going on
and you can go ahead and get all that
weirdness out of the way
and that's a good
that's a good question and it's good you
have a good heart for worrying about it
but um i think it's on him and on them
it's not on you she's got to release it
[Music]
uh
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america it's a free call triple eight
eight two five five two two five in the
lobby of ramsey solutions on the debt
free stage scott and malicia are with us
hi guys how are you doing well dave how
are you welcome welcome where do you
guys live fort worth texas all right
welcome to nashville and all the way
here to do a debt-free scream holding
the big red thermometer all the way
filled in i love it how much have you
paid off 189
whoa
i love it how long did this take that
was uh five years and one month wow good
for you and your range of income during
that five years in one month um 185 000
to 210
nice income what do y'all do for a
living i'm a nurse
and i'm oh sorry and now i stay at home
but i'm a fireman ah awesome to uh to
service two people who serve sir thank
you very much thank you
pretty incredible 190 000 over five
years am i going to guess right when i
say that's your house yes
you're half right half of it was a
rental house and half of it was our
house okay but you're a house and
everything yeah
looking at weird people yes i love it
way to go you guys so what's this house
worth
uh in this market you're probably about
450. not bad
i bet i love it wow
on a rental property what's the rental
property worth that rental property is
probably worth about 200 right now all
right very cool guys excellent job thank
you how does it feel to be your age i
mean you're youngsters what how old are
you i'm i'm 38 uh-huh and i'm 44. ah
just pups and you got the house paid for
we have our house paid for yes sir
thanks be to god i love it we got to
tell you something though this is the
second time we've paid off our mortgage
okay so the first time we were debt free
actually was in 2011 2011. so this took
us five years in one month but if we go
back to the very beginning we got
married in 2005 uh i was introduced to
you dave and to the baby steps by a guy
that i worked at the fire department
with we would listen to you in the
ambulance on our way back from the
hospital after transporting somebody
it's a little scary okay well yeah but
uh he was getting out of debt at the
time and i'd never heard of you so he
would listen to your show and you made a
lot of sense to me and i i took your
plan to malicia and we talked about it
read your book and we decided that was
the financial future for our family uh
the plan to get there it was so simple
but such a great road map and uh from
2006 to 2000 2011 we paid off two cars
our previous house and a small rental
property as well and so in 2011 we were
totally debt free she was in her 20s i
was in my 30s uh
and over the next five years i don't
really have an answer for you as to why
but we decided to go dave ish i don't
really can't really say why i wish it
was a straight line from there to here
but we took a little turn
we bought the uh the second rental
property not for cash and we decided to
move up in house so the previous house
that we had we sold and we moved up in
house so that's where we found ourselves
five years and one month ago i was with
the 189.9 what activated you to get back
on
uh
go ahead well we had we had already had
such success with your program from
early on in our marriage you know um
like like he said i was only in my late
20s and we were looking at our finances
and saw that we already had a paid for
house paid for cars no debt and we knew
this was the way we wanted to live
forever except for that except for that
part where you didn't except for that
yes yes you joke with people you're like
hey if you don't like not having a
mortgage you can always go get another
one it wasn't that we didn't like it but
we did go get another one thankfully so
over the five years that we didn't have
a mortgage
and
it was like kind of a
little slippery slope you know you start
to forget a little bit and you start to
get a little too cushy i guess at least
what that's how we were it wasn't like
oh we have everything paid off let's
just go party and forget all about dave
ramsey it was just like the five years
just was kind of a slippery slope and
then we ended up wanting to change
communities and move and things like
that and we wanted melissa to be able to
stay home and so now you you busted it
for five years and got out of debt are
you going to do it again
no
never convince me why not
i think well so i will say this the
first time through uh michael was not
yet born and jonah was very little our
lives were very different uh and this is
gonna sound like a first world problem
but it was not that difficult for us to
do the first time the second time
it took a long time it took longer it
was more arduous our kids were older so
our lives had changed drastically we
were doing more things more activities
more expenses and so
having to be patient for that five years
and one month was was a it was a tough
tough task so i never want to go back in
so by the time you got done you were
really sick of it yes sir oh we were mad
at it
yeah yeah it sounds like the more
sacrifice you had to make the less
likely you were to ever do that again
yeah the first time you didn't feel the
pain as much as
exactly yeah it was just the two of us
and so we could pick up all the overtime
we wanted and we just threw everything
we could just the two of us but we
didn't have many outgoing expenses and
things like that and so
yeah so i think we just thought it would
be just as easy but the second time
around it wasn't we had to throw kids in
the mix it changes everything we had
kids and more expenses and it was harder
but more rewarding because we did it
with our family yeah yeah we got to
teach them the lessons along the way too
which was really
they colored in this little thermometer
for us every time we made a payment you
can see the coding job
now that you're done
you don't have a payment in the world
the rental property's paid for they got
other rental properties still too we
have two total and that's it what's the
other one worth that one's probably
worth about 150. okay wow all right and
so you're with with retirement and
everything you're easily baby steps
millionaires right yes sir yes now way
to go guys yes sir and thank you and 40
years old man that's amazing i mean
that's that's very good okay so how's it
feel
fantastic amazing fantastic uh we just
it's almost surreal to even be here on
the stage to be quite honest with you we
said all the way through the journey
like one day we're going to be on that
stage with dave so here we are i love it
we are so grateful to you and what you
um imparted upon our marriage early on
that
kept us from fighting about money and
helped us always be on the same page
about money and to make these goals
family goals and um
i
i don't know
um what we would have done without it so
yeah wow way to go it's amazing thank
you well thank you we're proud of you
you guys are rock stars man and our kids
kids know your voice as soon as it comes
on the radio i love it in all your songs
yeah i look forward to meeting them and
their names and ages let's bring them
into the shot jonah is 12. uh-huh and
michael is six all right very cool and
they know what's going on then yes sir
they do
they know their family tree has changed
because of their mom and dad are awesome
yeah so what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is
um
wow i think it's get mad at your debt
and make your money work for you and and
the second time around it's been more
family focused so about the values that
you're teaching to your children
about giving yourself no answers and
being okay with saying no to yourself
and self-discipline and delayed
gratification and all the things that we
try to teach our kids i hope that they
learned through our example every time
we said no and every time we tell them
no and things like that life is about
being able to accept those things
and um and being able to um be rewarded
in the future for for that man delayed
gratification for sure they saw me um
put
super glue on my shoes and he zip tied
his fender onto his car to make this
happen and um and also being able to
live like crazy people yeah like weirdos
yeah well you are weird now you're
officially weird i love it does he have
a certificate in his hand is that fpu
what is that about this is the
foundations and personal finance that
you went through we went through it for
um for middle schoolers oh wow they have
both done um financial peace junior yeah
yeah so we made this a family affair for
sure oh yeah they're they're
indoctrinated now absolutely sure
we want them to be free we want them to
live free and be free i love it i'm
proud of you guys well done we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires because
you should be in that book that's
perfect that is your next chapter in
your story and you've already living in
that so very very well done a copy of
total money makeover for you to give
away and wake someone up so very very
very good job pretty incredible story
scott and malicia jonah and michael fort
worth texas 190 000 paid off that's
their house their rental properties
everything baby steps millionaires at 40
years old five years and one month
making 185 to 210 count it down let's
hear a debt free screen
three
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
four
three
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is
joining me as my co-host today open
phones at aaa
8255 225. meredith is in tampa florida
hi meredith how are you
hey i'm doing all right how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so found out last night that my rent is
going to be increasing by 62 percent
once my lease is up from
lower 50
yeah to 1700 a month so i'm i'm
currently working the baby steps on baby
step two and i wouldn't be house poor
per say i would still have a little bit
but my shovel would be drastically
dented that's pretty amazing yeah so
you're paying a lot like 1100 now
yeah 1100 now were you under you think
you were under the market before or the
market has just jumped that much
i think maybe a little bit of both um
honestly i feel like like i've looked
around since then and it looks like
everything in this area like people are
just flooding to florida and so i think
i think it's just driving up and most
things are comparable to the 1700 amount
that's coming around so
uh so you either move down in quality of
house or location
or you accept the increase
basically yeah and a lot of the
apartment complexes around here are
income restricted so it's too much to
move there uh but also we'll be pretty
strapped here so wanted to get your
input would you
sign the lease given the way the housing
market is uh the only thing i would
wonder as a caveat to that is if i don't
sign the lease and i go month to month
it's a 100 difference which i feel like
is pretty low for not signing the lease
so i don't know if it seems like maybe
it would be best to hold off pay the
extra hundred dollars a month and if it
seems like the market's gonna go out
what's your household income
wow is it a one bedroom and are you
living alone
so it's a two-bedroom and i have been
looking for a roommate because i'm
trying to really go cheetah intense and
all that stuff for baby step two um
which would have been great before but
now almost feels like
it's more than breaking even but it kind
of feels like it's a lot less pumps if i
were to get a roommate
how much longer do you have with that
with this baby step two with this
increased rent how much longer do you
think it would take
with the increased rent i haven't run
the numbers uh
i've again just found out last night so
currently it stands i should be done by
february um of 2024 and that's without a
roommate without a side hustle what do
you what do you do for a living
i'm an executive assistant
how far are you from work
i am in my living room right now
oh so i get to work remotely okay so
it's remote yeah
yeah
you could do some extra virtual
assisting on the side if that's
something you want to do to get the
income up right now i would probably
also get a roommate if you're cool with
that for a year to speed up the process
because that's just a long time to
remain in baby step 2 and not knowing
what the market's going to do with rent
yeah agreed so you would sign then and
just continue to no
no not yet i mean you've known about
this for 24 hours
so i'm going to um
how long will they give you to make your
decision
so i have until the 31st because it
needs to be a 60-day notice however if i
don't
um i have to do a 30-day notice from
that point onward uh well from may 31st
onward so you know hypothetically yeah i
i would say between now and the 31st you
have a new hobby and that's looking at
rentals
yeah
i mean you've scanned the market enough
to ascertain that this
is not they're not gigging you that this
is just the new price in the marketplace
you know they're they're not being
crooks or something like that there's
nothing anything wrong uh and and you
don't have a lot of options that are
readily apparent but that's 24 hours
worth of research so right you know i i
really think i'm gonna go looking for
that garage apartment out back of some
rich old lady's house or something that
uh
you know that that's 10 or 15 miles
further out
of your center of normal
behaviors
that's a little bit less convenient but
it's half the price i'm gonna look for
that needle in a haystack for a little
while i'm not gonna bet my life on it
but i mean boy if you could land
something back down around a thousand
dollars that was tolerable and was safe
and clean and that kind of stuff um if
it was a little bit inconvenient i'd
rather do that
uh but but you're not going to find that
in the first 24 hours you know you're
going to spend some time and effort to
to find that property if it even exists
i'm not saying it does 100 of the time
but one of the things one of my rules on
decision making is when i have two
possible options and both of them suck
i don't yet have enough options
that's a fair plan okay
so i want to put more options on the
table even if they're
uncomfortable for other reasons
sure you know other than just price uh
the price is right but it's
uncomfortable because of dot dot dot and
i don't know what whether the dot dot
dot is
tolerable or not but after that i'm with
george yeah i pick up extra work and uh
take in a roommate and uh try to try to
find another way to get at this housing
angle and being remote i mean you could
move further out to a cheaper area easy
temporarily this is not forever but as
while you're getting out of date and get
that emergency fund in place
i mean i i'm the world's worst i mean we
just moved uh in october
for the first time i don't move much i
can't stand moving it's like having a
root canal but uh we moved about 20
minutes further away from downtown
nashville
we were already about 25 minutes out of
downtown nashville which i don't go down
there that much except to eat good food
scene in nashville uh but uh but now it
feels like like we're out in the country
we gotta get up we gotta get a list and
go to town you know it feels like oh my
god and it's not that much further no
it's five ten minutes but it feels like
fifteen minutes but it's just feels it's
there's an emotional adjustment more
than a factual
yeah adjustment yeah that's what i want
to deal with that too we moved to the
suburbs with all these families and
she's like i want to be near nashville
where all the action is and i can tell
well you know with a young lady like
that i don't want to be right down there
in a minute though i mean my point is
it's it's more mental than it is actual
yeah sometimes to be further out and it
might change the
price equation substantially 15 minutes
might say 500 bucks to be 10 minutes
further out depending on which direction
you went and so on that that kind of
thing there's a way to think about it
i'm i'm not saying that's the answer but
um here's a good thing to keep in mind
all of you that are facing rent uh
increases and real estate price
increases and everything else the the
you know one of the classes i took
getting my degree in real estate was
urban planning and generally speaking uh
with no barriers which never exists
but with no political or geographical uh
or topographical barriers
if you take the downtown area of a the
central business district and you drop a
pebble there
the rings go out like in a pond
and the further out those rings you go
generally speaking it's cheaper now the
exceptions are when one of those rings
bumps into a piece of water
the price might go way up or one of
those rings bumps into a mountain the
price might go way up
and the other side of that mountain
might be way down because it's very
inconvenient to drive around it
or the other side of the bay tampa hello
you know that kind of a thing right so
there's
that that
ring theory breaks down when it bumps
into stuff yeah but generally the
further you go out into rule from the
central business district of a major
metroplex
the cheaper it gets generally now again
an exception will be political things
one of those is in nashville is the
county that we live in is out several
rings but it is the wealthiest county in
tennessee the 11th wealthiest county in
the nation
and so house prices here are bonkers oh
yeah
because of that but it's it's the quote
place to live so to speak that kind of
crap there's a new neighborhood across
from ours and the houses we're starting
it's all dirt still they were starting
at 700. i just checked back in they're
now 1.3 million dollars and it's still
dirt
but they just up the price they just
changed the sign housing beginning at
yes price is beginning at mark through
it mark through it mark through it and
keep raising them yeah you can but
that's but again
the whole idea being that if you move
out a little bit further
i will admit because i'm experiencing it
personally that you have a bit of an
emotional hangover and that you
feel like that you're further out than
you really are it's not that big a deal
because people that are
laughing all around america right now
they're hearing me talk about a
15-minute commute like it's a big deal
uh because they're like try two hours
and 15 minutes on a train playing
automobile exactly bus but the uh uh
again
just to challenge you because you can
always when you're renting especially
you can always move out a little bit
because it's a temporary move renting is
always camping it's glorified camping
while we wait to get out of debt and
build up the money to buy a house
so good discussion and boy it's a big
thing out there right now this rent it
is something else george camel ramsey
personality good hour this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life your money
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host as we talk about your money your
relationships your career your job your
mental health anything about your life
you want to talk about we're here to
work with you the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
matthew is in baton rouge hey matthew
how are you doing well miss dave thank
you we're blessed and highly favored uh
thank you mr george's also taking my
call today sure how can we help dave i'm
uh
well i'll just really quickly just a
short background
fpu graduate three years ago 18 months
debt-free 10-18 months debt-free so
three years here we
we
killed eighty-nine thousand dollars in
debt
um
we've got i believe in three times your
emergency fund i would like to be very
careful i have my six months in place of
expenses
i'm investing my 15
uh self-employed
and
we are forced to sell a house that was
given to us
three years ago but because the
family member passed away and in short
now we're going to get hit with capital
gains so we're doing a 1031 exchange
and i feel that i'm where i should be to
go ahead and start investing correctly
if i'm wrong with it but i have no other
choice unless i want to give my silent
partner a lot of my money
and i don't feel like giving uncle sam
that money
so pulling out the 1031 my question to
you
is
i want something safe i've evaluated my
risk factor my returns and my
maintenance and i want low risk good
return and low maintenance of course but
i'm looking to start generating the
revenue for my retirement
that's what i'm looking at y'all
all right so the house
you inherited it
and uh what was it worth at the time you
inherited it
what is worth no at the time you
inherited it what was it worth
uh
well we just three years ago i i
wouldn't know because well i mean give
me a guess come in for example purposes
give me a guess
well i'm gonna tell you 250 days okay so
that that's our example all right and
yeah so anything you make above 250
you're going to have capital gains on so
what will the house sell for
uh we have it on the contract at 285
okay
you don't have any taxes
15 on 35 000 it's not even 35 000 after
expenses when you're you're selling
expenses are also deductible
so i mean you're talking about 3 000 in
taxes you don't need to do a 1031.
yeah okay so the house was an active
donation not a true inheritance due to a
will or death it was oh i thought you
said it was an inheritance
okay
no that's okay that changes the math
though
that changes the math because now your
basis is what they paid for it which is
probably a little of nothing
exactly 21 000 yeah okay so now you've
got a big capital gain i'm back with you
on a 10 31. okay sorry that's okay i'm
just just making sure i'm touching my
bases here and so um yes
so why
have you had it rented during the three
years
no sir he they were living in it with
yusuf rupp so that was where the family
members were staying but before they
died and all that they took care of all
their
their property their their
last
their what they want to do you know
where they want it all given to so they
gave it all away and we said well y'all
just stay there yo just stay there and
we'll take care of you no problem but
now they're going so can you are you
sure have you checked with a tax person
that you can claim this is a rental
property because it has to be a rental
property to do a 1031 to another rental
property it doesn't sound like you
collected any rent
that's that would be correct i did that
talk with the accountant she's just
telling me that we have to you know do
the 1031 we don't want to put capital
gain on it but she's aware of your
inflected rent on it
sir she's aware you collected no rent on
it
yes sir i want you get another tax
opinion
because i i i'm not sure but i mean i i
you know it's a like-kind exchange and
has to be income property for income
property and there's been no income on
this property so i'm a little worried
for you in the event of an audit uh but
let's pretend let's go forward that the
1031 works uh and that my concerns have
been delayed you'd get some good advice
because i'm not sure
uh and you're gonna so you have 285
thousand dollars you need to reinvest
into another piece of real estate that
produces income yes
and so what are you you're asking what
to buy
in short
what was just a couple
ideas that you would say are safe
conservative
and to as a beginner i'm this is my
first one okay that
i have no clue that we love the
tennessee we thought about cabbage we
thought about commercial property here
and ran out to tenants but the economy
and the prices and real estate has got
us
so whacked out i just don't know what
but i'm forced to do it within six
months i believe is my price i gotta
close right
so you gotta find you gotta find a 285
000 property that you like that fits
your guidelines of
low maintenance low risk and no it's not
a cabin in tennessee it's it's a it's a
income producing property near you
uh and um that's probably another house
is probably what it is and but you're
probably not buying an old house in a
junky neighborhood you're buying
uh something that's a little newer and
is not going to require as the level of
maintenance and uh will serve you going
forward uh you've already got it under
contract to sell it why was it you sold
it again
well it was sit out there vacant it's
it's an uh keep running us away
no sir in the area of the state we live
in it would be torah full of drugs and
lord knows what else i got your word
okay before that town goes even worse
yes sir i got you okay i understand it's
not it's not something you wanted to
keep it's what it amounts to okay
so yeah you got what i'm looking for is
i'm probably looking for a nice
condominium
that that's a you know that's five years
old or something and it doesn't have a
lot of maintenance issues
that i can drop 300 grand into and are
250 grand into and um
just keep it real simple don't over
complicate this
but you do need to check with someone
other than your accountant uh in
addition to your account and get another
piece of tax advice and make sure that
this 1031 will fly yeah i would jump
onto ramsey solutions.com connect with a
good elp tax pro and a real estate agent
to help you start running comps and
going hey where's where am i going to
find some good stable rent in a good
neighborhood for this price range if you
can do that with cash i think you're
going to be in good shape yeah
so for those of you wondering what the
flip we've been talking about for the
last five minutes a 1031 tax deferred
exchange is what you do instead of
trading properties in the old days you
used to have to trade properties if you
wanted to move your gain from one
property into another let's say he had a
house to sell and he he wanted to not
pay capital gains on that 285 000 in his
case then he would have to go find
another piece of property and the person
that's buying his property would buy the
other piece of property to trade with
him and he could roll it over they
simplified the laws
25 years ago probably and started
calling it a 1031 tax deferred exchange
where you sell the property into a
special 1031 s that's the number in the
irs regulations 10 31
into a 1031 escrow account and then you
have six months to buy another property
and it allows you to roll your equity
into the other property as if you had
done a trade without any tax without any
tax implications today when you do sell
that other property now you got the old
basis in that rolled over so you're
going to get get your butt taxed off
then this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey your host
this is the ramsay show
we all know time is important it is more
precious than money than shiny toys or
winning certificates at work and like
spending money from an account when you
don't know how much is in it we never
know how much time we've got left so if
you could do one thing
one thing
that would make the time you have left
even more worthwhile wouldn't you do it
of course you would we all we all would
we get that
and we want to help you have everything
you need to be well
and that's why we're partnering with
betterhelp to give you a month of free
one-on-one weekly therapy when you
pre-order a copy of dr john dolone's new
book own your past
change your future it comes out
in
april but guess what if you pre-order it
you get a free month of one-on-one
therapy that will give you the tools you
need to change your future
because you get matched up with a
therapist based on your specific needs
this is an incredible bargain for twenty
dollars you buy a book and you get this
thrown in
wow
off the chart i mean i
this is i can't even imagine how much
money this is it's crazy now when you
read this life-changing book on your
past change your future you'll feel like
dr john's sitting right there with you
he'll make you laugh he always does
he'll make you cry he always does and
he'll challenge you he always does
and he'll make you think about your
health
the health of your mind and it didn't
mean when i read the book i really i
really personally enjoyed this it's
transformative stuff
and every one of us got one or two dials
inside of us that we could click a
couple notches on and get a little
better right
and that's true on anything but it's
certainly true on this so your get your
free therapy sessions by pre-ordering
own your past change your future twenty
dollars at ramseysolutions.com
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com
they have a 100 percent satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from kathy in arizona she says my
daughter just got married and her
husband loves your show and is budgeting
according to your plan for new couples
who are starting out and getting to know
each other it's hard to be on a tight
budget with no extra money for date
nights or even a yearly vacation with
both of them working full-time there
needs to be something to look forward to
besides just paying the bills shouldn't
your plan be modified a bit to include
adequate funds for these activities as
they get to know each other both
personally and financially
that makes me laugh that's good kathy
wow i don't know what plan she read
your plan is to have no extra money
right that's the plan i know and love
[Laughter]
honey you need to leave your grown kids
alone and let them run their own lives
you interfering mother-in-law
uh
what book did she read
oh
okay no we don't have money for date
nights in there when you're trying to
get out of debt
no we don't have money for vacations in
there when they're trying to get out of
debt and
this poor little couple
newly married will survive that they'll
make it a promised mom and they'll get
to know each other just fine because
they ain't got anything to do except sit
and look at each other so it's gonna
work out just fine i love that you said
as they get to know each other
financially yeah that's very interesting
so here here is what you do need to
guard against i'm making fun of you
kathy because you need to be made fun of
but um
but the the thing you do need to guard
against here that you are right about i
will take your side on this is if he is
being a control freak and clamping down
and your daughter doesn't have a vote
in this your daughter needs to speak up
because what we do teach is that both of
them have a vote
but we do teach to sacrifice to win to
live like no one else so that later you
can live like no one else and if they
both
are committed to getting out of debt and
they're going to sacrifice to win the
way we teach it is not going to harm
their little tender relationship as a
matter of fact it will draw them closer
together because unlike their other
married friends who are so freaking
snowflake that they're all they worry
about is being nurtured instead they're
actually sacrificing to hit a goal
together and that draws people closer
together than snowflaking in the same
room
that's uh that sums it up well here's
what i'm saying
their financial situation isn't clear
here we don't know if they're in that's
right the fact that she said they're on
a tight budget makes me think they're
probably in baby step two they're
probably broke he wants to get them out
of debt so they can go on vacation and
not come home with the vacation on the
credit card for the rest of their life
and mommy is worried about her little
princess they're newlyweds they're fine
i know they don't need to go anywhere
and and you know sh but seriously they
it's okay if they have no our budget
does not say you cannot enjoy your life
it does say
that you should tighten up everything
and not have a bunch of fluff in your
budget
uh in order to accomplish your financial
goals which is get out of debt and it is
worth the sacrifice and no it will not
damage their relationship beyond harm
and you know what creates that margin
for all that fun stuff getting out of
debt it's amazing how that works the
reason an old fart like me laughs at
something like this
is because i remember when i got broke i
mean i got married i was so broke i
couldn't pay attention
and i can guarantee you neither one of
our mothers gave a crap
about our little relationship so dave
should take sharon on vacation
my little daughter is not gonna no her
mother's like you you can people only
get your butt and gear and work that
would have been both of our mothers i
mean they would have had none of this i
mean but but it's a different thing now
so it's a little bit of a helicopter
parent kathy that's what we're hearing
if kathy cares so much just send him on
vacation no gift it to him
no
don't interfere she's already
interrupted these grown people be grown
people
you quit helicoptering
um that's what i read here now if kathy
if i'm being mean to you and you get
your little feelings hurt i understand
she'll call in or email you yeah she'll
send me an email but it's okay i'll
still love you and i'm just gonna make
fun of you for being a helicopter mom
and you're sweet you love your daughter
but you need to let her toughen up a
little bit it's not gonna kill her she's
not gonna lose her relationship her
husband's not gonna hate her she's not
gonna hate her husband because they
can't go out on a date night sharon i
didn't even know what a date night was
after we got married prior to getting
married we had date nights but after
getting married and i mean we were
married five years before this whole
date night thing that's true yeah you're
supposed to go out on a date on tuesday
night back then you're going steady
right that's what it was no we were just
married it's like the whole thing was a
date you know it wasn't like we had to
go out somewhere into a restaurant to
prove it so but it's just but that's old
fart stuff so the times have changed
get with it back before their ears ended
what began with an art before ought 22
you know oh my gosh but yeah uh yeah
such a boomer showing your age yes
definitely yeah i i just
but you know
but there is something about new york
i did i went to a podcast with mark mike
rowe this morning dirty jobs and mike
and i are like brothers from a different
mother on this stuff and so we were we
talked for an hour the podcast went on
way too long just two bucks
i think i messed up his podcast but um
um i don't know when it airs but y'all
be listening for it he and i were having
a lot of fun and they happened to record
it too so but we were just talking about
entitlement and snowflakes and
and i was bragging on the millennial
generation because i always do you know
that george i have a good reputation for
bragging on them the ones you meet and
hear at least but the uh well i meet
them everywhere they work on our team
there's a bunch of them and they work
hard they're the portions of the
millennial generation are amazing
portions of mart
but we love the portions that are and
and they make great that you know i have
great marriages we see them in here
doing debt-free screams and all kinds of
things
but the ones that are entitled
snowflakes the where they come from
is this right here
and that parenting is what leads to that
this right here this is who has a 31
year old living in their basement
that's really good at nintendo
really good at call of duty
and nothing else
and uh because you know why we
washing his own clothes it's just too
much to ask you know so making up your
own bed oh my gosh it's a lot of work
yeah so i i'm making fun of you kathy
but i tell you what if if it's not you
it's somebody else out there like you
that i'm making fun of you pointing to a
bigger problem there you go thank you
very much it's not about this it's a
macro discussion and you opened up the
can of worms
so yeah that's the thing so no um no we
shouldn't modify our plan
i'd modified it in 30 years
live like no one else so that later you
can live like no one else it's in the
bible
no discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
rim shot
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage chris and
jennifer are with us hey guys how are
you all doing awesome welcome welcome
where do you all live tucson arizona
cool welcome to nashville how much debt
have you paid off
330 thousand dollars
how long did this take just about four
years dave good for you and your range
of income during that time uh at the
start it was about sixty eight thousand
uh for one year throughout this journey
it jumped up to over three hundred
thousand whoa and we're back down to
about 110 now cool what do y'all do for
a living i'm a pilot in the air national
guard i'm a stay-at-home mom what
happened to get it up to 300 for one
year well i took a lucrative job
opportunity deploying overseas
and uh
it was a big sacrifice uh five months
out of that year was gone overseas but
um
that's what jumped us ahead so many
years yeah you made a ton of money in a
short period of time
paid a price to do it yeah through the
pandemic wow oh during the pandemic yes
sir
i was supposed to be gone for three
months and that turned into five
yeah because yeah
man
so you're uh a civilian contractor yes
sir time in the international guard i'm
back at my unit full time now yeah okay
all right but at that time i mean that
gig you took yes sir is in the sandbox
civilian contractor yes sir okay cool
all right so four years and 330 000 that
looks a lot like a mortgage was it uh
two cars and a mortgage yes sir wow
house has paid off look at the weird
people so i love it i love it i love it
where do you guys what's this house
worth uh today it's probably about 360.
nice
very nice and it's yours it's all mine
it's all yours i'll tell you what the
turf in the back feels so good on my
bare feet i bet it does i bet it does
i've heard the rumor that's amazing how
old are you two
35 tomorrow i'm 34. wow happy birthday
for the paid four house you guys are
incredible paid for 360 000 house at 35
years old wow busted it
so four years ago you guys had two cars
live in normal you got the mortgage what
made you go all right we're gonna go
hard at this thing oh we were so normal
i mean gosh growing up my mom always
played dave's show in the in the car um
i knew his voice and i knew the music
but i had no idea what the teachings
were about um but goodness gracious
through pilot school we were blessed to
meet uh jacob and cassie warren who
turned us onto your show they
were under 30 years old and had two paid
for houses
strategies so we're like we have forgot
to get on that group you're willing to
listen to them you're like whatever
they're doing let's do that these people
are going to be rich yeah they had two
little girls too and we were like if
they can do it and they're our friends
and just normal people we can do it too
absolutely they didn't look like they
had a superman cape or anything
they just just did it normal weird
people so they coached you up and got
you back involved now you're listening
to the show and actually listening
actually listening yeah i'm a pilot
the first thing i did was got into your
uh website and there was seven steps and
as pilots we checked checklists yep all
day every day i was like i can do this
come home to her hey show her the
amortization chart on our mortgage we
could buy another house with all the
interest that we were paying on our
mortgage a big shout out to bob barker
and casey woods who just steered us in
the right direction to make us go
gazelle intense with your program as
well wow very cool so he comes home with
he's all got his checklist you know he's
doing his pilot thing
jennifer what'd you say
at first i said no
no
i remember the first time you told me we
were going on a budget and um i was like
what what is a budget and that's not
enough no and then uh he took me to
goodwill and then he said this is where
you're going to shop now oh my goodness
and i was like what this is not how you
sell this there's dave there's nothing
sexier in embarrassment an
amateurization schedule and don't you
know we're supposed to modify this and
leave room for your vacations and for
your relationship and
i know that now dude
i'm kidding i'm just staying
the last thing oh my gosh but you know
what it became like a game i would take
20 bucks to goodwill and i would see
what i could get and wow you bought in
huh oh yeah no i totally i furnished our
house and our backyard with stuff from
marketplace and goodwill i think
everything is probably under a thousand
dollars bedroom sets couches play yards
all that
yeah and it's not junk no it's not drunk
no
it's amazing what you can get it is it
really is that was her full-time job for
a long time yeah
well and and paid for itself easy yeah
absolutely yeah yeah instead of uh
that'll be 50 000 and that'll be 150
000.
and the playset is 450. the kids don't
know the difference it's amazing how
much you save like we were looking at a
new sofa and it was like six thousand
dollars yep i got mine for 50 bucks oh
and it wasn't dirty nasty it's not
horrible no somebody wanted rid of it
somebody rid of it that's all it was
yeah one part of the story we just feel
need the need to mention as well um
the reason why we finished in four years
instead of six or seven uh just this
past august my father passed away
and thank goodness he was actually good
with money he had savings for retirement
but gosh at the age of 56 way too young
um fortunately though he was thinking
ahead and um and set us up for success
in the last 75 of the houses was paid
for by an inheritance oh wow from him
wow that was a huge blessing in in his
life well and it's something that uh
that when you did that you know he's
smiling absolutely this is what he would
have done absolutely yeah
yeah that's bittersweet
bittersweet i'm sorry for your loss
appreciate it yeah that's way too young
oh man well way to go you two you're
absolute freaking heroes all right now
tell america how do you have a paid for
house by the time you are 35 what are
the things you need to do to get out of
debt
two things for me is really have a why
you know have your goal
and the second is not just having that
goal but have that high definition
vision on how you're going to achieve it
that's exactly what we did we sat down
at the dinner table and we dreamed in
high definition on not exactly where we
were going to be not exactly when but
exactly how
i would say don't worry about what
people think about you you know because
um the right friends are going to stick
and the wrong ones are going to go
and you just have to worry about what
your family needs you know your goals
and um don't worry about the judgment
you know now we can give so
lavishly did you have some haters
i did at work so
while there's a short period of time we
weren't flying
and every day where are we going for
lunch i'm like i brought my lunch where
are we going for lunch i brought my
lunches and they're just hating on me
like oh you can you can spare you're a
pilot now it's okay you can go out for
lunch every now and then
i was sitting there with my uh orange
lunchbox every day i love it i love it
wow so jennifer some of your friends go
go stink eye on you well they're not my
friends anymore
she cut them out
just like that yeah don't mess with
jennifer that's it jennifer i mean he's
he's got lunch box she got there you go
hey i'm just saying wow way to go you
guys okay very cool very cool who were
your biggest cheerleaders
his mom
absolutely yeah she's listening right
now thank you angela yeah she used to
make him listen when he was a kid in the
car so he's a financial peace baby
all the way yesterday yeah i love it
very good
all right well let's bring the kiddos up
what are their names and ages natalie's
eight emily's five oh perfect cute you
gotta jump onto youtube just to see yeah
you guys gotta you guys gotta look
deeply into your radio and see this man
this is pretty incredible with the
stuffed animals that's a good why right
there absolutely that's a good why well
done mom and dad all right well here we
go we got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure
and uh also a copy of the total money
makeover book for you to give away and
maybe one of those friends will be
converted that used to be a friend or
something you never know
hardcore man i love it chris and
jennifer natalie and emily 330 000 paid
off in four years making 68 to 300.110
count it down house and everything let's
hear a debt-free scream
three
two
one
we're dead free
[Applause]
i love it
there's nothing better than those little
voices doing that because that means
that his mom their grandmother
legacy has continued listen to the radio
in the car and hear us now her
granddaughters are sitting there in a
paid-for house because of her man that's
powerful makes me cry i love it this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today colleen is in cleveland
ohio hi colleen how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
well i'm calling a
future planning question my mom passed
away
about a month ago and
the legacy that was passed down to her
was from my grandparents and
there's not a whole lot left
um just about when i divide it up
between my siblings probably about 15
000 a piece
and i'm trying to decide or figure out
how do i create a legacy that represents
the life of my mom it's my grandparents
i'm so sorry
what did she uh what did she pass from
um she actually died because she had
gangrene in her foot that um became
infectious she had a lot of other issues
but that's ultimately what what she
passed away from how old was she
76. okay so she's obviously a great mom
she was
and your grandparents too huh
yes they were good good
well that is a legacy right there
that the two of them those two
generations have
woven into who you are on
and if there was no money left that
legacy still lives
just in you and and and what you do to
pass it on
um what do you have in mind what are you
thinking about
i don't know my mom always loved to
create
spaces and environments and
opportunities for the family to gather
and be together and
my grandparents actually had a summer
trailer just on a piece of property that
was their summer home and that's where
we spent all of our summers my mom was
basically a single mom and
the inheritance from my grandparents
allowed her to live to the age that she
was at
so they saved very well and
we were kind of thinking about
is that something we should do we have
six children they all live relatively
close
um but it would be something that we
could all go to in the summers and hang
out and have campfires and camp out and
as the family grows we could put tents
out and that kind of thing
but we also want to be able to play for
like piano lessons and soccer clubs and
different things for our grandchildren
we have six children between us and um
two grandchildren right now
but sounds like a lot of work for
fifteen thousand dollars
it does like you're asking that 15 000
to work awfully hard
yeah
so um it sounds i mean i don't know what
a lot costs in your area that you're
thinking of
um
i think what i would do is uh
pick something
that is doable
um
and i don't know i'll tell you what ran
through my head and and i it there's no
there it doesn't mean it's the right
answer okay
um i'm i'm kind of channeling my inner
dr deloney here for a second um god help
me i have i have a little inner doctor
that's a really scary thought when you
think about it but anyway the very
little but the uh uh he's kinder than i
am but i i uh the the tent thing
on the lots is trying to recapture a
time that is no more
and i might try to do something that was
the new thing that is the way the family
does something rather than something
that is trying to recapture an old thing
that
is not anymore uh uh and also it just
runs through my head i don't know how
you buy a lot for 15 grand that'll do
that but i might be wrong um
maybe you can maybe you've got maybe
you've got one in mind i don't know but
if you do that that's okay i'm not mad
about it i i
i wonder if there's the thing that and
you every time you do the new thing you
say
brought to you by mom and grandmom you
know
and whatever that is and just and that's
the way you honor them and it could just
be that we all gather somewhere
and we use this money to pay for the
gathering
you know uh you know it doesn't
necessarily we have to own a piece of
ground and it's always the same thing
every time maybe it's uh we rent a place
for a week
and it's a couple of grand or something
like that and everybody gathers there
and uh you leave the money and let it
let it generate uh interest in the
meantime right i'm making this up i have
no idea colleen but
um i i think what is more important than
actually
selecting the perfect thing and if you
mess that up you didn't honor their
legacy is just going their legacy is
already built in the fact that you even
asked this question
colleen what's your financial picture
look like are you guys out of debt do
you have savings
yeah we're in baby steps four five and
six
we have
our emergency fund is fully funded for
six months and we're working on paying
the house off we have about ninety eight
thousand dollars left
on the house
i just go back to they were such good
stewards of their money and that's all
you need to do to honor them is be a
good steward of that and that looks
different for everyone but there's
nothing wrong with throwing it on the
house and getting the house paid for and
later on you buy the land when that time
comes you do it with cash you're gonna
honor them with the way you live your
life forever and the fifteen thousand
dollars is just the starting point
yeah it's it's it's not a million five
that you can create a foundation with
that's gonna always that the income off
of it is gonna be endowed and the en
what endowment means is you put enough
money in there one time that the income
off of it will do the thing forever that
is the honoring thing the memory thing
or whatever and it's not enough there to
do all of that um and so i'm going to
step back and do probably go george's
route or just pick something that
um
we just say
this is the new thing and each time we
do it we say brought to you by
your grandparents and this is the they
they value the fact that we gather
together and so we're gathering together
which by the way is a huge gift families
don't do that enough
um it's very difficult to do
chris is with us in cincinnati hi chris
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave
i'm glad to be here but i'm kind of um
not real good on the radio it's okay
just ask your question right quickly
okay we're not gonna miss you ask your
question what you got my question is i
got this medical bill on my uh debt
snowball it's about in the middle of the
death snowball
and the payment on it
is the highest payment monthly payment i
have it's larger than our
refinance mortgage
and i'm trying i'm wondering if instead
of leaving it in the middle and just
having it sit there if i should
pay this off first
ahead of some of the other loans that i
have
to get rid of that huge monthly payment
and you know i'd be able to put that
towards the other debt afterwards
but freeing that almost 800 a month
would
give me a bit more flexibility if
something happens down the line and we
need to
you know kind of scale back on on
paying off the debts
well what's the total balance of it
it's twelve thousand dollars right now
and how old is that medical debt
it was from september it was a surgery i
had in september okay pretty recent
well i would i wouldn't mess with the
debt snowball because it works every
time you work it and you're going to get
to that debt sooner than later with
these smaller payments getting knocked
out how much how how fast is all going
to happen right now on your timeline
if i left it where it was
it would take
around 13 months to pay off the other
deaths that are ahead of it it'll almost
be paid off then
it'll be paid off then 800 bucks on 12
000 in 13 months
it'll be gone yeah that's
well i think it's about 16 months
on its own yeah but i mean it's just
about going to be done you will have
eaten through it just paying the minimum
payments
yeah it's i'm just looking at like if i
were to
move the extra that i have i wouldn't it
would be i would often nine i wouldn't
i would stick right with the debt
snowball
i i think you're you're going to be done
in the same time regardless of which way
you do it if you follow through
but i'm going to stick with what we have
used for 30 years that has worked and
and that is you get those little ones
paid off you're going to get a sense of
traction you're going to get a sense of
destiny and i like the fact that you
dread this bill that you hate this he's
angry at it that you're angry at this
bill it's gonna cause you to lean in and
push right on through it so i'd leave it
right there as just something to be
pissed about
so it keeps you moving you know i use a
good righteous kind of anger here nah
leave it alone dude leave it alone i
appreciate that you're thinking about it
but stick with the plan it works i'm
with george that puts us out of the
ramsey show in the books
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host he's
also the host of the entree leadership
podcast as well as the fine print the
first season of that podcast is
online and available now and oh anywhere
you listen to great ramsey networks
podcasts and it's pretty incredible
check it out we're here to answer your
questions about relationships mental
health about your job your career about
your money your life it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five nick is with us in new
haven connecticut hi nick welcome to the
ramsay show
hey how are you dave great how can we
help
hey um i've been um
watching your youtube videos for a
little while now then i have i don't
think i came across this question that
anybody asked
i currently own a condo in new haven
which obviously has the standard
property tax hoac and all that stuff
but because the complex needs
some exterior maintenance done they've
added a special assessment on to
um our monthly payment so would you
consider
that part of the lump sum mortgage keep
it on as your as like the mortgage
equivalent and pay it out through
the five years that the condo
association has for the loan or would
you consider that a type of consumer
debt
that i should pay
that in that mix as well
how much is it
uh over the five years it's about seven
thousand
plus about 135 a month yeah
i it doesn't matter
you need to get it paid off either way
you're either going to pay it off when
you pay off the condo or you're going to
pay it off as baby it's either baby step
two or six but you're going to get
around to it you follow me
so um yeah it's there's not a and it's
probably no interest it's probably just
a straight assessment correct
yeah the the interest on the
loan that the condo association took out
is already stacked into our monthly
payment so i mean if you pay it off you
don't get a break
the the
they will they will let us pay it off
either on the month by month or
you know if i get a bonus at work or
something we can pay it off individually
whenever but they're not charging you
interest so it doesn't save you anything
to pay it off early
no yeah so as far as the interest you're
being charged is zero
it's a simple seven thousand dollars
divided by five years yeah 60 months so
135 a month yeah
so uh
i like the cleanliness of just getting
rid of what's your household income
um i start actually start a new job on
monday it'll be about 110. yeah i like
the cleanliness of not having it there
i don't try to like
my my i learned to quit thinking like oh
it's no interest so i'm going to use
this money and i i in instead it's just
a stupid bill
for me
um because you're not gonna get rich
because of either thing you do here okay
but getting rid of it there's a
simplification of your life a
cleanliness to your life you make enough
money i'm probably putting in the debt
snowball i don't know what are you
feeling george yeah i mean if you're in
babysit for and beyond and you've got
the cash i'm gonna pay it off but if not
i'm gonna just make it part of my my
debt payoff it doesn't feel like
consumer debt he didn't go into debt for
this so you can look at it as a
budgetary item that's on top of the
mortgage but i'm with dave and that i'd
rather not have it in my life and have
the cash flow back every month if you
have the cash to just get rid of it yeah
it gets paid
one way or another you sell the condo
you refinance the condo someday you pay
off the condo someday or you pay it off
now you have to pay it regardless so
it's gonna get paid it's not going away
so it's they've got a you know special
assessments a lien on the property so
uh if you sell it it'll show up in a
title search so um
you know it's it's going to get paid
but uh that's not the question so it's
just a matter of when and it's only
seven thousand dollars if it's seventy
thousand i might let it lay over there
baby step six
but it's just not that much lee's in
baton rouge hi lee how are you
i'm doing good dave how you doing better
than i deserve what's up
um i'm well i'm 31 years old married and
have two kids um self-employed lord's
really blessed uh my business over the
last few years i'm completely debt free
we i've rented for 11 13 years now
straight and have moved 11.
11 times in 13 years so needless to say
me and my family were looking to either
build or buy our first home and settle
down
of course with me being self-employed
the job has has really ramped up over
the last three to four years but it is
varied because i am 100 commission
so my two questions that i personally
had um
is i've got enough cash to i've cut i've
got a couple hundred thousand dollars in
my savings account
um i have about ninety seven thousand
dollars in a mutual funds
and uh and about another hundred
thousand in personal investments that i
personally invest in take out etc
with a 25 000 emergency fund
with looking at purchasing a home and of
course studying my amortization
schedules over the last
year of looking at homes
i'm curious as to whether you would
recommend
you know
the thought process of taking some of
the money out of my personal investments
or mutual funds and pay cash up front
for the home yes or not touch those oh
definitely do that definitely pay cash
okay
okay um
pretty
and so you would you definitely
recommend taking out then you're saying
out of the mutual funds account to put
that down towards the home it's not in a
retirement account it's just a mutual
fund right correct yeah what are your
personal investments in
uh i personal stocks where i i you know
invest day trade on the side um a little
bit of cryptocurrency etc um what's your
what's your household income what are
you making a year
well i'm a logistics broker um
and
it's it's really it's really increased
over the last three years so two two
years ago i brought in 125 000 last year
was 3.25 and this year is on pace for
between a half a million to 650. wow
but as the supply chain crap calms down
that's that income is going to calm back
down agreed and that's yeah and that's
what i wanted to press it all of course
with that being the case it's really
been blessed and you know i obviously
believe in the lord to keep his hand on
the business uh but yeah but i'm under
an illusion you're gonna make six and a
quarter the rest of your life
correct i 100 i'm with you yeah and if
you don't have a mortgage payment that
changes the scenario as far as you being
commissioned and worrying about what's
going to happen this month i mean you've
been working your tail off and you're
good at what you do so you deserve every
bit of this and i'm really happy that
you're prospering this way way to go
dude touchdown uh but i'm i'm not gonna
be under any illusion that i win the
super bowl every year yeah um
you know i think you'll still be in the
game you're a stud you're gonna do that
but yeah i'm going to use this as a
windfall
as if you got an inheritance or as if
you've got a
one-time bonus or whatever a signing
bonus whatever something like that i'm
going to treat it like that and just pay
cash for this house and now i've got
that piece of my life that has settled
forever that's very cool definitely
paying cash dude definitely paying cash
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
guys if you're uh wondering whether to
buy or sell a home this year we got some
answers you can expect the market to be
a lot like last year
price is still kind of cray-cray
interest rates are expected to go up and
uh what can you make of all this well if
you're buying a home you might be up
against some heavy competition and hefty
price tags and increasing interest rates
and if you want to sell a home chances
are it's going to sell quickly top
dollar of course that all depends on
where you are every real estate market's
different but to win in any market what
you really have to know what you're
doing
so you need to work with someone who
knows what they're doing
you've experienced real estate agents at
your finger you have real estate
experience real estate agents at your
fingertips through our endorsed local
provider program as ramsay trusted pros
they care about your values and keeping
more money in your pocket check out
ramsey solutions dot com slash agent
this is not amateur hour it is not a
time to go it alone out there you need a
pro and not a beginner somebody does a
lot of transactions and knows their
stuff in your corner ramsey trusted
agents are just that ramsey solutions
dot com slash
agent kathy is on the line in buffalo
new york hi kathy welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave and george i'm so
i feel so very blessed to be able to
talk to you um how are you guys doing
today
great how are you
i'm i'm good um
so i'm gonna try to keep my question as
brief as i can
i'm a registered nurse i've been i've
been one since 2007.
um i'm a single mom with no support from
my son's father
i have um i i have been on track to get
all my debt paid off
and
um i'm also a veteran i was in the army
and had a injury that resulted in us
increasing my disability from 10 to 70
the
the amount that i got from the
disability increase
is
um i'm holding on to that so that i
could pay my student loans off in august
of 2021
i was injured significantly i shattered
my
elbow
and it required surgery
which then has left me with um minimal
use of my arm
um i'm at the point now where i'm
realizing that my recovery is not going
as well as i thought
um
it had the injury not happened i would
have paid my student loans off and only
been left with
the debt on my house
and now i'm confronted with do i hold on
to the money
or do i go ahead and pay my student
loans off
keeping
my thousand dollars in my emergency fund
i'm sorry
tough time it's a tough thing you've
been through
and all the pain to boot
um
so two different injuries one one when
you were
serving
and one as a nurse
yes okay on um
uh unassociated with each other right
yeah okay
all right um what's the balance on the
student loan
uh approximately 13 000.
what were you making before you got
injured this time
well this this year uh was the first
year that i cleared over six figures my
um my growth was 100 around 105. what
type of nursing were you doing
um i was working at a cancer hospital in
buffalo and um
doing clinic work
okay so you're interfacing with patients
directly
correct okay and so they usually
the use of your elbow becomes a really
big deal in that setting
um the problem that i'm having is i i
could probably do administrative stuff
but in order to be medically cleared to
go back to the job that i have they
won't allow me to come back light duty
which means i have to be able to
function in 100 capacity
um including bedside nursing and that's
not something i can do yeah so you may
need to change jobs and but i i but i
bet you there's some administrative type
nursing that you can do with this
limited mobility can't you
um i believe so yes yeah yes and i'm
looking at my options there's always
case managers yeah
care coordinators uh legal nurse
consultants so i'm aware of those yeah
um my question really lies in the fact
that i'm
i have an amount that i could pay my
student loans off
well here's the thing
the the shakier your future income is
the scarier the idea of plumping that
down on the student loan is agreed
absolutely yes so let's solve the future
income issue and then plump it down
you need to decide what you're going to
be doing next because you're not going
back to the old job
okay because it does give me a bit more
security mentally and emotionally but
i'm not going to sit there and burn
through the money i want you to go get a
new job
right right okay
okay so you're only i kind of have the
feeling this is the first time you've
said all this out loud
even to yourself
well no to myself but um you're not
going back there never said it out loud
to somebody else i know but you're not
going back there
have you said that out loud to yourself
um
because i break that breaks your heart a
little bit doesn't it
yeah i'm i'm grieving yeah um i'm
grieving that part of it yeah yeah not
only the pain and the injury i don't
want to believe
i don't want to believe that that's this
is it yeah oh yeah it's not it it's just
time for a change because
the the elbow's not gonna do the thing
that you did before is what you told me
now i i'm not a medical person i was
going with what you said
no i
you're correct okay
well you're correct is what we're saying
so um
yeah but it's still it's it's it's part
of the
i mean
the injury you you got hurt and that you
have the actual physical pain but
there's also the emotional pain of all
this change that this forces on you and
after you've been struggling and
fighting and scratching and clawing as a
single mom it's just not fair
you know it's just it makes me mad and
it's not even me
you know yeah i've gotten past that okay
all right the hope is that
you got you got done with the pity party
already okay
we agree
i've moved on okay
party over
now this isn't forever but the hope is
that you heal up and we get you back to
doing exactly the thing you want to do
but for now we've got to have a new
picture of what this looks like in the
season as you heal and that looks like
finding that new job getting stable
getting rid of the debt and then we're
in a whole different place the absolute
saving grace wonderful news of this
whole conversation and you already know
this but i'm going to say it out loud
it is that you happen to have picked a
career that gives you almost infinite
options
there's a thousand different things you
can do as a nurse
you know
thank god you're not a doctor or that's
a specialist and it can only do one
thing
you know there's a thousand a labor
worker that that needed that elbow to be
able to do my job yeah yeah but there's
a bunch of different things you can do
with that elbow messed up that are that
may make you as much or close and once
you land that then putting plunking the
money down on the student loan is a
no-brainer agreed
i agree yeah but i i'm with you i'm okay
to say we're in the middle of a storm so
we're going to push pause
not and not we're not going to be lazy
about this we're going to address the
issue
i mean like you said no i i agree with
that and i i'm just having a hard time
uh mentally switching from i've been in
um gazelle intense mode to get all my
depth paid off and then all of a sudden
i
my gazelle hit a brick wall yeah gazelle
broke his elbow
perfect analogy
yes so we get we give the gazelle a
break and let him heal and let her heal
and um
then we restart and you know you're but
you're you're done
we've just got to stabilize the
situation to write the check is all
and and then you're gonna be able to do
it i
i cry with you i can't imagine what
you're going through you're a warrior
warrior princess i'm proud of you you
keep fighting it girl
don't let up don't let down
so um
i could tell by the way you addressed
all this it's
pretty incredible i i think i think at a
year from now you're gonna look back and
go well oh well
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 dollars about two years
after that i got a remote job that pays
me a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
all thanks to what i learned at bethel
tech you could be next get started today
at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt-free stage
dan and heidi are with us hey guys how
are you we're fantastic
cool so you're walking around our lobby
with t-shirts and say weird people yes
yes and we in our lobby we all
understand what that means but if you
walk through the mall with those shirts
on you could get arrested right people
keep their distance
they do
they're weird people they wear t-shirts
they're proud of it i like it all right
so how much debt have you guys paid off
194
834 dollars love it how long did this
take 27 months good for you and your
range of income during that time we
started around 150 000 and ended about
200 000. cool what do y'all do for a
living
i'm in sales
i do accounts payable and receivable for
a local school district ah wonderful so
what kind of debt was this
195 thousand dollars actually it was all
real estate dave we had uh three homes
we had been out of debt other than the
real estate for a couple years
and we went to we took financial peace
at our church and that got heidi all
fired up she's like we need to pay these
mortgages off go heidi
go hiding
wow so that's what we did and uh
there were three mortgages there was
actually four mortgages we sold one of
the houses
that was kind of the hardest thing for
me to do because i bought this house
years ago and it was a retirement plan
i'd you know listen to real estate and i
wanted to do that kind of
retirement and uh
so when we decided in the class to sell
that that was that's how you did that
spring
we sold it for about a hundred and i
think we owed about 25 20 20 25 okay so
75 of the 195 chunk with that the rest
of it your cash flow out yes okay you
knocked him out and that's your house
and everything house and everything so
it's official you're weird people you're
weird
so what's your home worth
uh probably about 250 000. cool and what
are the what's the other real estate
worth uh probably
we would we decide about 250 000 between
the other two homes
yes
somewhere in that range about a half
million dollars and paid for real estate
right very nice very nice so how much do
you have in investments in your
retirement that kind of stuff
before or after
we the new administration
so i
no we have about uh
uh four hundred five hundred thousand
five hundred dollars so your baby stops
millionaires we are on this we did it
we're very close yay way to go you guys
thank you proud of you well done okay so
the church is teaching financial peace
university you guys go in there and
heidi goes uh
you're the salesman i'm the numbers
person we're paying off these houses
i'm all in you're coming with me
that's why i told sharon we've been
married 40 years i said if you leave i'm
going with you
absolutely oh man way to go you guys
thank you excited now that busts into
everything the culture tells you not to
do
you're perpendicular that's why we call
it weird people and that's why weird
people around here is a compliment
because normal's broke and in debt and
you're not either you're millionaires
with paid for real estate paid for home
um
and so you you came you bucked right
against the culture
how did that feel when you first started
doing it
it was it was different go ahead well to
me it was a little bit
more on my normal side just because i'm
the budgeter
i'm the one that says we should spend
this amount of money and dan was like no
i've been single for a lot of years and
i can spend whatever i want because
it was only me but now i said now it's
the both of us
if you'll look beside you you will
notice it's not only you yeah
absolutely uh yeah
how long y'all been married ten years in
january all right good good so now that
you did it now that you busted through
it the tough 27 months got rid of that
property made you cry a little bit when
that one went away and uh uh but now
you're free
how's it feel
awesome great
such a weight lifted off so it's worth
it absolutely yeah every bit of it every
day nowhere to go but here from here but
i mean your baby step seven you're just
gonna pile up money now
you guys gonna buy more property you
think
we're looking about a beach house maybe
he's got a shell in his pocket a shell
in his like a magic trick and that shell
does not come from nashville
i think he's been dreaming he has been
dreaming this uh he's carrying that
around this is a thing right here good
good for you i think you should that's a
good idea
very well done well you got you need to
have a goal you need to have things
you're aiming at and you know your
enjoyment of the money that you're
outrageous generosity uh these are the
things that that make all of this
worthwhile
and uh and and you're you're on track to
do all of that so way to go all right
now people are listening and uh they say
all right how did you do this what do
you say the key is to getting out of
debt
mine's pretty simple spend more money or
spend less money than what you're making
that's a big a big it's simple but it's
that's the deal yeah mine is stick to
the budget that we set up
or that i set up and he would make one
one or two changes and then i'd say you
got to stick to it
and you can change it but now you're
locked in baby exactly yeah yeah that's
the trick to get them locked in yeah
that's good
very good way to go you gosh now it's
habitual we have
the app and we just every time we spend
two dollars on a soda it goes in it goes
in the every dollar app and then we know
where it's going heidi's watching yes
she is
nothing's slipping by her i like it i
like it hey you gotta have a plan and
this is it man so it's a system now and
you know those of us that are
salespeople uh we have a tremendous
ability to earn money
uh but almost all and i'm one almost all
of us that have that that uh that zest
to that ability to go make money selling
uh also have that goes with that we have
this
mistaken idea that we can out earn our
stupidity and so you need a heidi in in
there going no here's the plan stay on
the plan now you're locked on the plan
we're staying on the plan
and i had to do that to myself and and
sharon with me of course years and years
and years ago but i realized that that's
what i was doing i was trying to out
earn my stupidity yeah i did the same
thing
when i was we got married
uh i was gonna run the checkbook pay the
bills i'm the man of the house that's
what he does and uh
so but what i would do was if if it was
12.85 it was 13 in the checkbook i just
round up then i wouldn't have to worry
about balancing i always knew i had more
money in there than what it said and
she she really didn't go for that
that's not how you do it
that's not how
so it works for us she pays the bills it
does the checkbook well way to go you
guys we're very very proud of you
congratulations we got a copy of the
baby steps millionaire book for you
since you've hit that milestone you can
enjoy that you should be in there
and you're yet another person another
couple that has pulled that off and uh
also a copy total money makeover for you
to give away to someone
uh
tell folks out there i mean you've been
married 10 years you guys are how old
56.56 okay
so it's not too late
you can do this in the last 10 years you
guys have completely revolutionized your
lives and in the last 27 months you have
for sure
yes
you can do it you can do it whenever
right exactly because a lot of the folks
come on the show or 30 years old or 27
years old or whatever but uh you know we
had a lady on here the other day that
was 70 something
um that did our debt free scream and so
it's you know it's just math
right and it works when you're 70. and
it works when you're 27. uh you know and
so you you can just do this and you guys
did it i'm so proud of y'all well done
thank you very very very well done all
right it's dan and heidi from ohio 195
000 paid off in 27 months making 150 to
200 100 debt free house rentals
everything
they are weird people and baby steps
millionaires to boot count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two one
we're done
[Applause]
this is how it's done
man nothing boosts the sound of freedom
i'll tell you that
well they are a true example of the two
ends the nerd and the free spirit that
love each other so much that they decide
to work together to accomplish goals
together and they gave up each of them
gave up pieces
of things to get to where they were
going that's beautiful sacrifice well
done
very well done over 14 million dollars
paid off in debt-free screams so far
this year wow
wow
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today proverbs 27 17 is
iron sharpens iron so one person
sharpens another
luisa may alcott said it takes two
flints to make a fire i'm dave ramsey
your host george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and about your money
carmen is with us in los angeles hi
carmen welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um
i'll try to keep it short but i got
married about a month ago
i have no debt i've been following you
for years no debt and i have a house and
my husband um he's new to ramsey he's
got a house and he's got some vets so i
moved into his house i'm going to be
selling my house
so with that the proceeds from the house
um
do i put that towards his mortgage or do
i pay off
um his debts
that's where i'm kind of wondering what
to do yeah what kind of debt does he
have outside of the mortgage
um outside of the mortgage it's about 80
000 um he's got some credit cards he's
got a trailer
a utv and uh solar
okay well that kind of debt would fall
into baby step two in our plan and the
house would fall into baby step six so
we're gonna pay off that 80 000 first
but my my bigger concern is is he on the
same page financially does he want to
stay out of debt once you guys are out
of debt
yeah we're trying to do the baby tips to
get out of debt and stay out of debt
okay
i just want to make sure he's on the
same page have you guys gone through
something like financial peace
university what's his knowledge of our
plan
um
he doesn't really have much knowledge
about the ramsey plants i've you know
kind of been
telling him about it and you know i
watch you and i listen to you um
but he's sort of new to this whole thing
you know budgeting and stuff so i'm
going to be you know doing the budget on
every dollar
i just don't want you doing this solo
and he goes well i'll do whatever but
you're going to be doing it this has to
be a team effort so i'll give you it as
a wedding gift if this all works real
good lee wants a new truck
i'm sorry i said this all works real
good till he wants a new truck
yeah well he's got um
our cars are paid off he's got a mustang
you missed my point
you missed my point
yeah yeah
yeah i get it now yeah when he decides
when when it's no longer convenient for
him to go along with this idea
it's not his idea anymore that's when
this is all going to turn into a bad
plan
so um yeah i'm not trying to beat him up
and george isn't either that's not the
point he just is he just does not know
what you what the three of us are
talking about and but i i really want
some emotional relational
commitment and buy-in from him based on
knowledge not based on he's just doing
what his new wife wants him to
do okay
if i'm you i want that and that's your
safety because here's the problem if you
take the money from your life and you
use it to pay off his mess and he wants
to go back into a mess
you're going to be like triple pissed
off
right that's always wondering if i
should just use it to pay down the
mortgage no it's his mortgage too
same mess yeah same guy yeah so the deal
is you guys what i what i want you to do
is invest some time
in the two of you
uh let me just give you a wedding gift
go through financial peace university
i'll give you ramsey uh plus and and
that's every dollar and everything built
in and the two of you go through that
and before you do anything with this
money
the two of you need to look at each
other and be completely
down to your soul
aligned
on this because you've got a real clear
picture of what this is
and we're all just kind of hoping he's
going to come along and and all of our
concern here is not really about your
husband it's about all the other times
we've heard this story five years later
and it didn't turn out well yeah because
we didn't get alignment so i think it's
an opportunity relationally for you all
to get alignment and that's what george
was bouncing what happens is when you
leapfrog the baby steps which is
fantastic that you get to do this with
your financial situation there's no
sacrifice and when there's no sacrifice
there's no true behavior change and i'm
not saying that he's not willing to
change i just need some proof before we
go do this nice thing and then he's back
in debt three months from now or forcing
or aggravating you because he wants to
and now you're the nagging new wife
rather than
because we weren't aligned on this is
how we're going to live our lives yeah
so hang on i'll have kelly pick up we'll
get you signed up as a wedding gift you
guys go through financial peace
university before you start writing
these checks
in the meantime just put that money in
an account and also by the way you need
to get the the situation changed with
his house that it becomes our house with
your name on it
and um
there needs to be wills done on both
sides that that house is yours
upon his death and accounts you don't
pay off his house and he leaves it to
his kids from the first marriage
or something like that no thank you or
his mother or whatever i don't care
because it was his house until you pay a
bunch down on the mortgage and then all
of a sudden it's not his house anymore
it's our house so we need to get that
lots of clarification there real clarity
you do all that then this is a very safe
and good thing to do with the money
michael is with us in austin texas hey
michael how are you
hey dave i'm doing good how are you
better than i deserve what's up
hey i have a question for you i have a
rental property that i'm looking at
selling due to the current current
market value increases
and with that money from selling the
rental property i'd be able to pay my
house off yay but
but
i am a business owner and with the
current supply chain dilemmas that we're
having i'm thinking that i may need that
cash to invest it back into the business
here in the future why so
do i pay the house no why what's wrong
with your business
well just supply chain needing needing
it potentially for
overhead or something like that
nothing's wrong with the business it's
just well something's wrong with it if
you have to feed it
that's true okay so what what i mean why
would you run out of business
why would why would the supply chain
shut you down
because uh so we're in we're in roofing
and uh roofing materials are not readily
available okay so you're having trouble
getting you're having trouble getting
shingles and so forth okay correct all
right
all right so this is not uh investing
into your business this is causing your
business just to stay open
so yeah correct yeah you know are you
making payroll are you staying open is
everything okay so far
yep yep yep but it's just the unknown
right yeah petroleum
is it i mean shingles are still
petroleum-based aren't they
correct correct which really screws this
up okay
yeah do you have any retained earnings
or savings for the business
uh yes yeah how much
uh about five six months worth how much
how much uh uh
shortage are you anticipating
uh we're anticipating this to continue
into 2023.
yeah but this being are you completely
shut down you can't get it at all or
you're getting limited amounts
it's it's delays yeah it's just the
delays so we're we're forecasting
everything we're watching everything and
we're monitoring it we're on top of it
it's just again it's just the unknown
well i need that i mean as a business
investor will i need the cash to put it
into the company at some point what's
gross revs at the company now
uh about nine million
okay
and what's the house selling for
a house will sell for about 550
and still owe about 240 on it
okay so we're discussing 250 000 keeping
a 9 million operation open
if you're if you're off by 250 000
you're screwed you're not gonna make it
anywhere
okay yeah it's 250 isn't going to take
you out 2.5
3.5 may take you out
yeah correct so this isn't going to save
you anyway
okay so i'm paying off my house for sure
and then i'm going to just start making
the radical adjustments in the business
and so yeah you're being very wise to
operate this the way you are
but i'm piling up uh every dollar of
income you get in the business right now
once especially once your house is paid
off we're going to just be in emergency
mode and build retained earnings so that
you build your own internal line of
credit
where you just have a huge freaking pile
of cash to weather the storm because the
problem with it is you've not just got
normal supply chain stuff now you got a
petroleum-based product
in an oil crisis
on top of it so ouch
that's what i was afraid i was hearing
okay good luck with it brother you can
do it i think you're sharp enough to
turn it you're gonna be all right but be
careful that puts us hour of the ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's
[Music]
debt free ramseysolutions.com
you